they look like young sweethearts just
goofing around until this chilling boast
day three after murdering somebody whoa
they admit to committing a murder and
it's worth it the victim according to
prosecutors the girls you're lying
that's not what happened is that what
happened for real let's find out
no
oh my Dave it's what
murder and it's worth it the victim
according to prosecutors the girl's own
father Daniel helseth put in the 25
th the dad was a fitness and travel buff
who loved to post videos online
including these moments as a doting dad
there's Sierra but he reportedly didn't
approve of his 16 year old daughter
Sierra dating 18 year old Aaron Guerrero
and he wasn't alone his ex-wife
Elizabeth a former Nevada Republican
state senator also had a problem with
her daughter's relationship not because
of the age but because he's Mexican
after they banned Sierra from seeing
Aaron Sierra's father disappeared he's
been missing for two days in his Works
called his family's called I've called
his ex-wife's called and there's nobody
answering the phone okay this is so they
banned her from seeing the guy
she's 16 he's 18.
I kind of get it I kind of don't
but I don't know him and I don't know
her I don't know him and it's none of my
business until you're going to murder
him for that
I mean murdering stuff aside just the
parents like Banning the kid from seeing
someone else in the high school nothing
to happen I've seen it too I've seen it
happen multiple times I just seen I just
generally just doesn't end well it
doesn't work no it does not because
unless you're gonna be hovering over her
shoulder to see wherever she's at or you
just forbid her from going out ever yeah
yeah which now you don't have a daughter
you have a prisoner yeah so here let's
sign up I know there's something very
wrong going on here there was indeed as
friends found out when they checked in
on Hall Seth's home in Las Vegas that he
had been renovating but there's a dead
body in the garage we just found hulseth
had been stabbed to death and his body
set on fire cops say Sierra Hall Seth
and her boyfriend took off in her dad's
car right after the slang they were
arrested Days Later 400 miles away and
so my friend was like oh my God why
would you take his car that's so dumb
you're never gonna get away with it
they're 16. 16 and 18. they're not done
they're teenagers and obviously the re
the reasoning is not there yeah but
let's get lost just just the fact wait
you you guys are bugging at he took the
dad's car no not the fact that the
reason why of someone disappearing is
because he forbid the daughter
the thing I picked you off was a car
this thing is so funny he's like oh your
dad won't let me see you so we're gonna
kill him so I can never see you again
when I go to prison
okay that's where you take thought is
the car hey man there was some other
dumb stuff before that in Salt Lake City
after apparently trying to dodge a train
fare prosecutors say they found that
chilling video on the girl's cell phone
it appears to have been taken in a tent
while they were on the run at one point
Aaron put his hands around Sierra's neck
the two were also caught on security
camera buying bleach and other items
cops say were used to clean up the crime
scene I spoke to Dr Keith ablo about how
such a girl with a seemingly idyllic
childhood let's clean the crime scene
and leave the body there bruh
and take his car
I think what's the skin
the skill thing it's not even just that
this happened or this murder happened
but three days afterwards she don't feel
any guilty nope she in bed with her
boyfriend she's happy that's something
that's that's yeah that's the real signs
of something real something's wrong yeah
a lot of your no mental health stuff
y'all we need to stop bringing up mental
health some people are just [__] bad
that that's some other [__] you don't
feel no kind of nothing yeah no way no
God damn
and it's not like they shot the man they
stabbed him repeatedly that's vicious
you know what people don't understand
that whenever I have this argument with
people because I haven't been multiple
times and I say that stabbing someone is
worse than shooting someone
you have to walk up to the dude
yup you have to feel the flesh with the
knife you understand what I'm saying
there's something very there's there's
fighting back that happens you're
fighting back they're struggling and
you're just that's
um
yeah who was it 14 times
what jumps out at you from the video is
the complete lack yeah there seems to be
a disconnect in which the perpetrator or
perpetrators don't even seem to consider
what they're doing to be real in a
certain way and that's why they don't
emote in a way that we would consider to
be quote unquote normal day three after
murdering somebody whoa the teams
haven't entered a plea if convicted a
murder he could face the death penalty
but she's too young and faces life in
prison
uh I think you should face two death
penalties because she's his daughter I
think it's more foul to chase part of
this person but anyway yeah imagine
raising a girl damn and she chooses a
boyfriend she's known for a year over
her dad she known her whole life God
damn that's a tough way to go out
murked by his own daughter
and for what that's well at first I
really thought it would post that on
social media uh it's on the phone which
it doesn't make it better because when
they're gonna find it even if you delete
the video they have some ways to find
that video anyways I'm not gonna be the
one to say that oh well that's the new
regeneration or whatever I'm not gonna
bring that on the generation or whatever
that's the [__] up individual that's a
messed up individual messed up thing to
happen that's crazy sad and unfortunate
and I guess the parents were right man's
evil too
you just proved them right
you prove them dead right but you proved
them right it's crazy
there's nothing much to say really
there's nothing really much insightful
that I'm gonna that can be saying
there's nothing insightful that I can
say about that bro
that's so crazy yeah the video is just
still the craziest part it's the
craziest part nothing else tops the
video it's really a game for them
because whether they post it or not it's
like that was a reflection that they
captured of their mood at the time three
days afterwards
it's hard to have any sympathy if I'm on
a jury and I see that video I say hey
hey yo put the death penalty on for the
16 year old too [__] that [__] that if
that's what you filming a couple days
after bye like maybe there's probably
something in teen psychology and the way
their brains function where like remorse
for certain things or whatever might be
a little bit more difficult for them to
exemplify our peer pressure you know in
Social context makes them act normally
if they're not maybe maybe it's like
there's something like Teen brain I
don't know but it's just a very chilling
video to see when you march your own dad
and then you good yeah because like I
could see situations in which a child
could you know shoot somebody okay and
three days later act normal I could
honestly see that
there's no way they process stuff is
just different and I'm telling you the
shooting thing
the shooting is very impersonal yeah
it's it's very remote
it's all about if you talk about gang
violence you go somewhere you go and
then you just run you don't really see
things that you don't usually see the
blood gushing out you don't see stuff
like that you don't see the if you stab
someone 14 times
they struggle they screaming that's your
father screaming and struggling and
three days after seeing that
you're good not a random person or
someone that you were
you think is an enemy it's not like you
your mental things is an enemy really no
your own father three days after that's
what you I mean and there's something
about the fact that they didn't post
that it's something about the fact that
they didn't post that is that when you
post something and you in it or you
record something in the intent of
posting it there's something that I know
I'm talking to different people now I'm
just gonna film this and just gonna be
like yeah whatever huh don't say don't
film that like you said it's in the
moment it's one thing that they're
having a little moment that they're
having is the more I think about it the
more you you're right the video was the
sickest part the more I think about it
shush
whoa
no I think I think the video just
captures what they really feel about the
whole situation damn they don't really
care and so yeah anyway we wanted to
share this because this one really
surprised me uh so let us know what you
guys think in the comments below man